if you are 22 years old you are entering  first of all some of the greatest years  of your life because you have to  understand this next five year window is  when you don't go practical and safe  this is not the time to get the job mom  wanted you to this is not the time to  try to maximize as much money so you can  buy a fat whip this is when you can  grind at your highest levels because  there isn't all the  baggage that comes across from like you  may have college loans respect it's hard  you may have the expectations of your  parents mentally hard fake hard you may  have a lot of other things but this is  the time to be massively risk oriented  what you should do is go and travel and  learn go and start that business that  you've always wanted hook up with those  three teammates and start that band  you've always wanted i know that there  are so many of you that have no idea of  what you're going to do with your future  nobody's ever been luckier than you  please recognize it